coming up for next week in Brussels a
Luxembourg Presidency PNR migration and
historical artifact
welcome to the agenda passenger name
record the was lambasted proposal which
was allowed for the collection of
traveler information will be the big
vote of the week at the Parliament Peter
now was put on a back burner Emmie Pease
push to get data protection reform in
place the worry has always been the
watering down of fundamental rights if
P&R was allowed to pass at the committee
meeting any piece could be in for a long
haul as they need to decide what kinds
of travel PNR should be applied to and
how long information can be stored it
was an EU council presidency that
started in the 3rd of July and how do
they celebrate with a picnic hopefully
they got a few sandwiches in because the
next six months are gonna be anything
but a picnic for Luxembourg the Grand
Duchy takes on their 12th presidency at
a time of turmoil for Europe the Greece
crisis still cast a dark shadow along
with migration and security ministers of
Luxembourg will descend on the
Parliament to present their priorities
making the rounds of committees all week
their priorities include jobs and growth
competition the single market and social
issues and sticking where the Luxembourg
MEP s will get the chance to grow the
former prime minister of Luxembourg on a
Lux week's revelations as a Parliament's
special tax committee gears up to
present its findings after summer it
hasn't been the easiest ride for the MEP
is leading the push and getting to the
bottom of member state tax practices and
especially preferential tax breaks to
multinationals access to information and
requests for meetings with industry
bigwigs haven't found the right response
mr. yonko we joined at a joint setting
of a special tax and economic and
Monetary Affairs committees by one of
his right-hand men Pierre Moscovici
Commissioner for economic and financial
affairs and don't forget that five
national finance ministers will also
present themselves before the special
Tax Committee on the same day
EU leaders a finally green-lighted
imagining plans to relocate thousands of
refugees now at the turn of the
Parliament to vote and discuss those
plans
40 thousand migrants all
in Italy in Greece will be voluntarily
taken in by other member states over two
years to try to share the burden
Parliament had pushed for 50,000 but
it's a situation in member states hands
EU leaders have also approved twenty
thousand migrants waiting in third
countries to be provided with sanctuary
in Europe the civil liberties committee
will vote on Thursday the recent
pictures of Isis militares to strong
historical artifacts and the ancient
city of Palmyra have angered many but
what can be done not only in Iraq but
all over the world to ensure that
historical artifacts are better
protected the culture committee will
hold a public hearing with experts from
the International Criminal Court UNESCO
and Interpol to discuss not only what
they can do but how to share
responsibilities and go after the
criminals find out more on Monday and of
course don't forget the Greece who
continued to dominate the headlines next
week and as well we have an agenda take
care and enjoy the week